We sit, we talk, but we talk
over a glass of wine.
That's what makes
this show special.
What's off limits?
Nothing's off limits.
So, I didn't wanna make two
Alien movies back-to-back.
How did he convince you?
Um, Steven Spielberg
sent a helicopter for me.
You're a God damn liar.
I'm gonna take you
on a full experience.
Oh, snap.
Who did you have
the opportunity to work with
where you was like,
"No, I didn't,"
that you regret?
Michael Jackson.
What?
Yeah, that happened.
What do you feel
is the biggest miss?
Even someone that
sounds like me, or someone
that looks like you,
we can make it. You know?
How are you feeling
about that?
Now? Like sh*t.
Do you wanna cheers
or you don't wanna cheers?
There is a window for certain
women to be successful.
This is big. Bigger than big.
Gotta create from a pure place.
I heard that.
What I really wanna get into—
Do I have to sit through this?
Do I have to continue
to sit here?
I'm pushing 60 years old.
Damn!
That was f***** up,
what you did to Don Cheadle,
by the way.